Prized since ancient times for its alluring
fragrance, today musk can mean any of a number
of substances used to scent perfumes.
However, while in our modern era most musk
is synthetically produced, when it first came
on the scene, musk was only found in a scrotum-like
sac on the bellies of male musk deer.
Musk deer are found throughout Asia, including
in Afghanistan, China, India, Mongolia, Nepal,
Pakistan and Siberia.
Small, the largest barely reach 2 feet in
height and weigh no more than 40 pounds.
The male of the species has a scent gland
sometimes called the musk pod that sits between
its belly button and genitalia.
Resembling jiggly bits, early on the Sanskrit
speakers who started harvesting the gland
used their word for testicle, muska-s, to
refer to both the gland and its product.
The first use for musk was in Auyervedic medicines,
the preparation of which required the gland
first be dried and then ground.
At this point, it is said to have a sharp,
repulsive, animal smell with “ammonia accents
that resemble urine and castoreum.”
Eventually, however, it was learned that by
heavily diluting the stinky powder in alcohol,
the bestial smell disappeared, which likely
made the medicine much more palatable.
In addition to removing the animal stink,
the dilution also revealed an underlying pleasant,
complex aroma.
Making its way through ancient civilizations,
deer musk became highly prized and very expensive.
By the dawn of the 19th century, pound for
pound, it cost more than twice that of gold.
Later, as cheaper, synthetic substitutes became
available, they were likewise called musk.
Today, musk is still harvested from musk deer,
and while the Convention on the International
Trade in Endangered Species of Wild Flora
and Fauna (CITES) regulates their harvest,
poaching remains a problem.
Other animal sources of that musky smell include
civet cats, sperm whales and beavers.
For instance, secretions from beavers’ castor
sacks located next to their anal glands have
a musky/vanilla scent.
This substance, called castoreum, is commonly
used in various perfumes, in some cases used
to create the “new car smell,” and used
in many foods as “natural flavoring,”
in substitute for vanilla.
Certain non-dairy creamers are just one of
many foods that sometimes contain castoreum.
Yum!
Another common musky additive to high end
perfumes is Ambergris.
This begins as a large, compacted mass of
the indigestible parts of a squid and other
gross stuff in the intestines of a sperm whale.
No one knows for sure how it emerges from
that dark, stinky interior, although the most
obvious explanation, poop, is the most popular.
Floating on the ocean until it washes up on
shore, the best ambergris spends years oxidizing
from a combination of salt, air and sun.
Prized for its unique scent, ambergris is
in high demand by perfume manufacturers and
the amorous alike.
In fact, high quality ambergris can sell for
$20 per gram (about $9,000 per pound).
As you can imagine, there is a thriving industry
in ambergris hunting, and the competition
can be fierce.
Luckily, there are other sources of musk available,
including plants like the Abelmoschus moschatus
and Amgelica archangelica, as well as several
chemical compounds including aromatic nitro
musks, polycyclic musks and macrocyclic musk.
Some people lack sufficient amounts of an
enzyme, flavin monooxygenase 3 (FMO3), such
that they cannot digest choline or convert
trimethylamine (an organic compound) found
in lots of common foods including red meat,
egg yolks, beans and fish.
As a result, the compound, which smells strongly
of fish or B.O., accumulates in their bodies
and is released in their sweat.
As you can imagine, this can be a socially
debilitating condition.
Other conditions can also be diagnosed by
smell.
Schizophrenics are said to sometimes sweat
out more trans-3-methyl hexenoic acid, which
gives them a super sweet smell, like over-ripened
fruit.
Diphtheria is also said to have a sweet smell,
while typhoid is known to smell like bread
baking, and TB sometimes smells like beer.
On the other hand, those with asthma and cystic
fibrosis can be diagnosed by the smell of
their breath, which is said to be a bit acidic.
Liver and kidney diseases can make the breath
smell of fish, and untreated diabetes can
make it smell like rotten apples.
There’s even a condition named after maple
syrup where people can’t break down leucine,
isoleucine and valine (all amino acids).
While on the up side, their pee smells like
breakfast, on the down side, in the most severest
forms the condition can cause intellectual
disability and even
brain damage.